[Music]
hey everybody what's going on what am I
doing over here I don't know you're
always there I need to just give I need
to just make myself a place where I'm
just like back here
like Lincoln in the damn Imperial
Memorial and [__] you know he's sitting
on the throne that's what I need every
time I every time I start the show I'm
never [__] in where I'm supposed to
be well if you got in here earlier you
would be able to see the [__] before I
started on the on the thing that's what
it is is that you try to [__] hog
everything up over here I just can't run
into that because I'll knock my books
over and uh on top of that I'm pissed
off
because I just brushed my teeth and I'm
sitting here drinking [__] orange
juice I thought of that I know I'm
[__] drinking it it's going
you know how funny you should have
waited so long they can't smell your
breath over the over the Internet my
teeth were [__] yellow man that was
fun I was asleep I fell asleep watching
with YouTube running
because I was asleep oh I didn't know
that yeah I just woke up like five
minutes ago because remember I told you
like a little while ago oh we're doing
the show and you were like yeah yeah
like you're awake then yeah I fell
asleep he never listens to me no that's
why that's why we're always late because
it's like I'm here I was like I started
getting ready like 20 minutes before I
started mixing my makeup and you know
getting my notes and all that other kind
of stuff and then like it's getting time
it's getting time and I'm just like uh
wear it
I don't know I don't know what happens
I don't know what happened I just got
all this [__] I gotta deal with you got
all this [__] I got yeah I guarantee you
I have way more [__] yeah
let me tell my story you tell your story
okay I got all this [__] I gotta deal
with
it yeah okay
yeah
um so uh it's another Monday yeah and
it's another haunting Monday
Zach says I just got back from a walk
and the humidity is here kill me please
yeah right I mean it actually was nice
this morning when I left for work at 6
30 in the morning but um when I went out
for lunch it was like unacceptably hot
you're not not looking forward to it not
at all
uh Amanda Marie Serenity says hey Tom
and Jenny how was your weekend uh pretty
fun we didn't really go anywhere um but
we got a lot of [__] done around now
yeah we had no money to go anywhere Tom
got the bedroom painted
yeah the dark blue so it's done it's
like midnight blue it's really pretty
yeah so I'm excited about that you said
you had enough paint left to do uh
accent wall in the gym right yeah yeah
that's a good idea yeah that's a that's
a really nice color yeah it's a really
nice color there may be enough to do all
the walls really I didn't think it would
be enough because our room has like
really high ceilings so I thought it
would be like
because this room here yeah this room is
a small room and it doesn't have high
ceilings in foot I have more than a half
a can of paint well this room took like
two uh like two cans and I almost ran
out yeah it's a lot bigger than the out
of the room that we're talking about
that's true it's a lot bigger
it's true
but uh yeah so this episode right here
we're slowly working our way through
season five and we didn't do dark dreams
because we did that one before like I
don't remember why maybe somebody
recommended that one but this one
so this one's season five episode six
and it's called nightmare upstairs and
when I was looking looking back through
like all of our you know little haunting
thumbnail uh things and everything like
that I was like wow they had a lot of
episodes that had nightmare in the title
we just did one called nightmare
Bridgeport and then there was one called
nightmare in the Attic which is a
completely different story to this one
yeah nightmare upstairs nightmare
downstairs nightmare in the front yard
nightmare in the backyard nightmare in a
booty
that's the porn version yeah
[Laughter]
she did do one called my ass is haunted
yeah yeah I mean it's the same as
nightmare no lie that was the sequel
yeah some people do have nightmares in
their booties yeah
[Laughter]
let's not get started on that I'm
a [__] side track well yeah that's
okay I mean this is not a huge it's
gonna be Belladonna and Lexington Steele
Mexican steel yeah I'm [__] drunk
yeah I was gonna say
still
anal experience nightmare in the booty
all anal experience yeah I just thought
I saw that in a uh like a marquee one
thing with flashing lights yeah there is
no badge penetration just just hang on
sir
it's a nightmare
Zach said nightmare in the toilet is
going to be dealing with later after my
dinner tonight yeah yeah that's
commonplace that's complex that's not
even paranormal did you eat a Taco Bell
just not even paranormal it just happens
that's that's a whole other episode
but yeah so and what I'm thinking too is
there was an episode called nightmare in
the attic and then there was one that
was just called The Attic Yeah man they
needed to come they need somebody else
to think of the titles I'll think of
some titles come on
they didn't just make them up on it they
just make them up on a spot probably
yeah you've said that one already
because there's so many seasons Echoes
from the grave I guess from the past
right it's from the ground that goes
from the [__] I don't know eventually
there'll be [__] like
unique hunting unlike all the other
hearts
professional yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I'll take with a different name
that's another one
yeah yeah I mean you know hunting with a
made-up name
[Laughter]
Harding with the main name that isn't
made up
yeah they have all kinds of [__]
holy [__] yeah
Zach said he didn't eat Taco Bell he ate
uh three Walmart brand breakfast
sandwiches okay I can feel them
digesting as we speak I don't think I've
ever had a Walmart breakfast sandwich
now that I'm thinking about it is the
frozen ones in a box that he's talking
about I don't know or ones from do they
have like ones that you can buy that are
like like you could would get it like
Circle K or 7-Eleven or something I'm
terrible I've had breakfast I've had
breakfast sandwiches from 7-Eleven and
that's those are actually pretty good I
will tear Walmart up I'll eat anything
out of Walmart
as long as there's food
I was gonna say as long as this no you
might not want to say that because it's
like here's a mop Chow Down
uh I said yeah it comes in a box the
ones in a box good and cheap
got that Malt-O-Meal cereal in a bag the
[__] fake Captain Crunch
those are pretty good oh yeah yeah hell
yeah I mean they're pretty bag the size
of a damn pillow they're pretty similar
to like the the name brands they're much
cheaper just gotta go down way to the
bottom and get those
but uh yeah I don't buy a lot of stuff
peanut butter Captain
peanut butter Captain yeah peanut butter
Captain Admiral crunch
exactly Admiral peanut butter
fruit circles
all right
fruit rings I think they are actually
called fruit Rings yeah probably a fruit
ring I think that's what they're called
I'm trying to remember like all the
generic all the generic names they have
for him
honey Nest ew honeyness cereal honey
Nest yeah that sounds kind of gross
thank you murder Hornet uh give us two
dollars for Zach's toilet I don't know
how giving us two dollars is gonna help
Zach's toilet any let's talk about this
haunting cake [__] around too much oh
this is a good one though this is this
this was actually a good episode good
episode I don't know if I believe a word
of it but um it's it's a good episode
making some [__] hellacious claims
yeah
um this was pretty scary [__] went there
yeah some of it sounds like
kind of like Poltergeist phenomenon some
of it sounds like haunting
which is a mixture of like ghost stuff
apparitions and things moving according
to Steve mayor
and um pretty badass Apparition they had
an investor it was an investigator that
was there right she's getting bed next
to her and she turned around and looked
and saw their human form it was just
with nothing but just a black face with
a big swirling cloud in it which uh yeah
that's the wildest that would be pretty
[__] freaky if you saw that yeah
that'd be a wash that you could just
feel the evil pulling you in on it
um that'd be a wild
wild uh [__] experience and uh the
girl got attacked by the eyeballs flying
around her which that happened to me in
a bad house I was like yeah it's kind of
like I had to be the bad house I was in
the house it was bad
it was like I was in two houses that
were bad but the one I call the bad
house
I felt like I got attacked by something
couldn't see it just like something
looking at me eyes invisible eyes
all over yeah it was weird
like it was bearing down on me yeah yes
I think the same thing happened to my
buddy Eric he used to want to talk about
it
but yeah so this story right here took
place in Arkansas
uh and it began in the summer of 2001.
now as they started doing in uh season
five they did a little Flash Forward so
they had like one of the characters
being like oh [__] like with like a
black shadowy doohickey guy like
attacking her or whatever
um and then the narrator
Anthony call saying uh you know this
family discovers why this house is so
cheap you know what I mean it's that
kind of thing I love that I thought that
was really funny because I even wrote it
down
they got the ghost discount
well that's what I was thinking it's
like they're sitting there going oh we
couldn't believe our look this beautiful
house and it was so waiting so I'm like
[__] didn't you see the Amityville
Horror that never works that well also
there was some um
doppelganger
events yeah see that that kind of [__]
freaks me out apparitions that look like
family members
and um that's been reported in in a
couple of poltergeist cases that sounded
kind of plausible
um very rarely is that reported in
haunting
but that was weird weird phenomenon what
they're reporting now remember this is
just compelling testimony from people
that supposedly saw it I don't know if
it really happened
um you'd have to I'd have to be there
uh to form my own opinion
but it's kind of hard to get a bunch of
people together and concoct something
unless there's just definitely some kind
of monetary motive you know selling a
book or
this is really
supposedly happened after the era of
where you could sell a book and make a
bunch of money on it yeah you could get
10 people together
pay them and end up spending a hundred
thousand dollars to produce a book and
make a hundred dollars off the book
sales you know
the the the day of [__] making a
bunch of money off of a [__] fake
case like Amityville Horror that has
been long gone
uh you can't really make a bunch of
money off of a paranormal story anymore
there are just so many of them and it's
been true they've really proliferated
yeah because I mean you know there's so
many TV series and movies and [__] like
that so it's like really hard to kind of
uh you know win or you winnow yourself
out from the pack yeah and why would
somebody in Hollywood pay you two
million dollars to to do your ghost
story when they just write up a totally
fictional one that's better
yeah yeah and then just claim that it
was real it's based on a real case yeah
yeah it's not like anyone's Really Gonna
care all that much as long as the
movie's scary
but yeah it's interesting because now
we're talking about doppelgangers
because remember when we talked about I
think the case we did last week which is
the Allen house
they said they didn't say this on the
show like on the reenactment that they
had seen doppelgangers of like their
friends and family in the house as well
they said they said that like in um in
the book The guy wrote but they didn't
put that in the show so I thought that
was interesting that this one has a
doppelganger element like a couple of
people saw like doppelgangers yeah which
we'll get into but that see to me that
kind of [__] doppelganger is always like
freaked me out I'm not really sure why
but I think if I saw
like if I knew that you weren't home or
something like that but I saw you like
very clearly like walking through the
house that would scare the [__] [__]
out of me you know what I mean that's
freaky that I think that would be like
even more scary than like seeing like a
[__] legit like ghost walking around
in this story The doppelganger says
stuff you know every now and then like
love you bye-bye and it is yeah we'll
get it done yeah that like I said that
would like freak me the [__] out if that
happened
since she goes downstairs and sees her
sister's getting her hair done
yeah
David June says maybe we're the
doppelgangers
[Laughter]
murder Hornet said My Doppelganger has a
doppelganger some Inception [__]
foreign
oh my God that was a great [__] show
is that still on probably not I really
liked that show though we used to binge
watch that all the time but uh yeah so
uh so this happened in 2001. so the
family oh my God Pookie what are you
doing tearing [__] out she's tearing a
rug up over there the family is named uh
the van Landing hams
uh Terry is the mom and I think the
dad's name was Blake right and this
happened I think they said it was win
Arkansas which I'm assuming is w-y-n-n-e
I'm not from Arkansas so I don't really
know but that's how I was assuming it
was spelled
so the hubby Blake he's a truck driver
so he's gone a lot which is you know
kind of par for the course for a lot of
these uh things like the the man is
always gone so it's always kind of like
the women and the kids that are left to
deal with all the Paranormal shenanigans
uh Terry also works though she works in
a law office now they have three kids
they have a son who's eight and his name
is Ethan and then they have two
daughters who I don't think they specify
how old they were they just said they
were both teenagers uh their names were
Heather and Brianna now for a little
while while I was taking the notes I
kept like mixing the two girls up
um so so sometimes if I say oh Heather
did this or Brianna did that it might
not necessarily be the right girl but
it's it doesn't really matter I was just
like because for a while I was like wait
I thought that one was Brianna what the
[__] going on so yeah so I was like
confused at first they're Southern their
sisters are interchangeable
it's stupid because I think only one of
the sisters like the real one was on
there talking yeah but then like the
actresses they had played they didn't
look anything like each other so I don't
really know why I kept confusing them I
don't really know what the [__] was my
problem was I wasn't drunk or anything
seriously but um but yeah
so Heather and Brianna are very excited
because they are sharing a room over the
garage and they said that it was this
really really big room and it was almost
like its own apartment like it was kind
of like removed from the rest of the
house and we kind of laughed when the
girls just said we could do whatever we
wanted and I'm just like what exactly
did you want to do up there teenage
girls letting letting boys climb up the
[__] trellis and doing drugs and [__]
like that I'm just you know allegedly
but yeah so um now Brianna I guess
Heather didn't really notice anything at
first but Brianna said that she
immediately felt uneasy about the house
and didn't really like it like when she
went up to the room she's like she
immediately felt like somebody was
watching her like they even had they
interviewed the dad and everything like
that and he said yeah as soon as we
moved in she was like yeah I don't
really like it in here she said if she
it made her really uneasy like
particularly that room
so apparently nothing really
earth-shattering happened for a couple
of weeks like after they moved in
but two weeks after they moved in uh
Terry the mom she's kind of like doing
housework or whatever and she notices
and see [__] like this like I said [__]
like this is like way scarier to me than
like overt stuff she notices that they
have like all these framed pictures like
on a tabletop or a mantle or whatever
like as you do and she notices that a
bunch of them have been like turned
around like facing backward
and she's just kind of like oh well she
figured like one of the kids had done it
just you know [__] around her as a
prank or whatever
but then like she goes in the other room
and then she comes back and then all the
pictures are laying there like face down
like on the table
and so she goes to the kids and she's
like what the hell like did one of you
guys do this she said too that some of
the ones on the wall were turned around
backwards also
so she thought the kids did it asked
them and they said no we didn't do it
and actually I think the kids said too
that like the same [__] was happening in
their rooms like some of their uh
pictures were turned around and all that
other kind of stuff so I don't know if
she entirely believed that the kids
didn't do it but they said they didn't
do it it's typical Poltergeist light
type phenomenon yeah that's yeah
like turning the pictures around and
whatnot
so then
um the next thing that the next big
thing that happens seemingly
um was I guess these this started out
and it was just kind of like stuff that
was sort of far apart because it's like
you know two weeks you know with nothing
happening and then there was like
apparently nothing exciting happened for
like a month after that
so then like a month later the girls are
in their room
and they start hearing I guess their
room was like an attic type of situation
like like I said it was over the garage
so they hear footsteps like coming up
the stairs to their room now at first
they didn't panic because they thought
it was their little brother Ethan and it
said sometimes when he was scared at
night or something like that like he
would come up there like to hang out
with them
so they thought it was him but then they
heard they said it very very clearly
sounded like somebody like a body like a
person falling down the stairs so of
course they thought it was their little
brother like he had tripped and fallen
so they like rushed out there this is
like oh my God the kids you know broken
his neck or whatever but they go out
there and there's nobody out there
um also they showed I don't know if they
saw this or not but they showed like the
lights kind of Flash in like all
paranormally or whatever
so then they run downstairs and they
tell Mom and Dad
now dad says oh I'll just check this the
stairs when I get home it's probably
nothing the house is just settling blah
blah and they're just like okay but that
for real sounded like somebody falling
down the stairs which doesn't really
sound like the house settling but
whatever so like the parents didn't
really believe them so they were a
little bit uh frustrating
so then evidently
um again nothing happens for like a
month so like I said there's kind of
like a long period of time in between
the incidents at first I guess which
like that's pretty common for this type
of thing
so a month later though the girls come
home from school and they go up to their
room and it's all [__] up like
somebody's like ransacked it
and they're just like what the you know
because they just came home from school
they haven't been there all day
so the mom comes in it's like what the
hell happened in here you guys are gonna
clean this up what'd you guys do to your
room and they're like dude we just got
here like we didn't do this but of
course she doesn't believe them she's
like you need to clean this up before
dinner you miss Koreans blah blah like
that kind of thing so they're just like
okay whatever and they just start like
cleaning it up now while they're
cleaning the room up
there was like
I guess they described it kind of like a
wind like in the room like wind started
blowing them in the room like they
couldn't figure out where it was coming
from
and then all of the [__] like the trash
that was on the floor like some of it
like floated like up in the air you know
what I mean it's very very Poltergeist
type of situation
so they see this and obviously uh
freaked the [__] out about it as you
would
so they run downstairs and basically
tell Mom uh the shit's haunted we
probably need to do something about that
um Mom of course doesn't believer and
straight up calls her daughter like the
real lady straight up called her
daughter a drama queen so I was like
that's that's nice mom
you know what I mean she's like
I don't know so she's like I'm so that's
why I didn't believe her because she was
always making [__] up I guess
so at this point they say that the Two
Sisters still keep having these weird
experiences over the next couple months
which I guess were kind of centered
around the attic room that they were in
and then comes one of the freaky
doppelganger incidents
so Heather is talking to Brianna
I think I can't remember which one was
older I think Brianna was older but like
I said I guess they were like around the
same age
so they're in the room and I guess
they're getting ready for church I think
they said
and
so Heather's in the room and she's
looking for something to wear and
Brianna is in the bathroom like you can
see like if you look all the way down
like you can see into the bathroom and
like the doors open and Brianna is
standing in front of the mirror like
brushing her hair
but her back is to Heather
and so Heather's like talking to her and
she said I was talking to her for like
half an hour so it was like a long time
where she was like talking to her and
thinking that it was Brianna while she
was just standing there brushing her
hair
and then after a while like she's like
okay well you know we better get going
or whatever and Brianna looking in the
mirror without turning around just says
real frequently bye Heather I love you
and I was like that would be like so
[__] freaky if that happened that's
like that kind of stuff is really scary
to me
so um Heather's like okay well that was
weird she's like I'm gonna see you in
like two minutes like because we're
going to church together so why are you
telling me like bye but whatever
so she goes downstairs and when she gets
down there Brianna is sitting at the
dining room table and their mom is doing
her hair
and she's like how'd you get down here
so fast like you didn't pass me on the
stairs like you were just upstairs where
she's like what are you talking about
are you high or whatever she's like I've
been down here the whole time and Mom
and Dad said the same thing she's been
down here the whole time like Mom's been
doing her hair like all this time so um
so yeah Heather's like well who the [__]
was that up in the room then because but
then she realized that she's like I was
talking to her for half an hour I don't
know if like she said anything back to
her until she said the freaky by Heather
I love you thing but she'd been talking
to her and she said and I realized then
that I had never seen her face like
because her back was to me the whole
entire time so she knows now that that
was not her sister and that's like
freaking her out which you know again
understandable
so a few months after that
um I guess the whole family is in the
living room watching TV in the evening
and all of the photos again they have
all the framed photos like there on the
tables and they start like all falling
forward like in sequence like dominoes
or whatever and then some of them like
fall off and break like the glass breaks
and stuff
and then they all very clearly hear a
sound uh which obviously sounds like a
body thrown down the stairs
now I think Blake is at work at this
point because like I said he's a truck
driver so I guess he's always gone like
for you know days weeks at a time so
he's always like staying at hotels and
stuff
so uh Terry said that around this time
she was always like calling him up like
at hotels like wherever he was being
like telling him about all this crazy
[__] that was going on the house and he
said he felt really bad about it because
he was always gone and he couldn't
really do anything like I said I don't
know if he believed it until later
because there was something that
happened later that he saw that he was
like okay like he finally accepted it
but up until this point he was still
worried about them though because he
knew that you know the mom and the kids
were freaking out and something was
bothering them and he couldn't do
anything about it so that was like
bothering him
so the following week uh there was
another doppelganger incident
Terry and Brianna were like at the
grocery store or something and then they
come home and they pull into the
driveway
and they see this girl I don't remember
if they said what the girl's name was
but um I think they did but I don't
remember what it was but um it was a
friend of Brianna's
and she was walking like she I think
they said she came out of the garage and
like walked across the driveway
and I think they called to her but she
didn't look at them
and then they both they're like oh hey
there's what's her face like what is she
doing out here it's like she's not
answering and stuff so then they go
inside the house and that girl is inside
the house like with with some of the
others like sitting on the couch
watching TV and they're like weren't you
just outside and she's like no I've been
here the whole time actually we thought
it was funny because didn't didn't the
dad say it's like she was here the whole
time or like the way he said it was like
you said he sounded like BTK yeah like
when the like his uh tone the way he
said it or whatever
but yeah so that was another one where
they were like holy [__] we just saw
something that wasn't that looked like
her but that wasn't her you know what I
mean
so then three days after this incident
uh Brianna is getting ready for a dance
recital
and while she's in the room like the
door creaks open by itself
and I guess this doesn't overtly alarm
her but she's just kind of like okay
and she still has a little while before
she has to go so she turns on the TV and
like sits down to you know kind of chill
out before the recital or whatever and
then that kind of wind kicks back up in
the room again and then this black like
missed shadow figure thing was like
pushing on her like it kind of like
jumped under like attacking her you know
what I mean like while she's in the
chair so she starts like screaming and
freaking out and everything
so the dad goes up there to see what's
the matter because she's screaming
and he said when he got up there that
she was just completely white like she's
just gone completely white as a sheet
and then she was like [__] terrified
and they also saw that she had like a
bunch of scratches on her back and the
sister said that the hand that did the
scratches there was like note with like
it was way bigger than a human hand is
basically what she said so she's like
even my dad's hand was like not big
enough to like make scratches that far
apart you know what I mean
so uh this incident finally got dad on
board with yeah there's some paranormal
[__] going on in the house
now at this point Brianna is like yeah
I'm not gonna be uh staying in that room
anymore and who can blame her really
but for whatever reason Heather decides
that she's going to stay in the room so
like Brianna moves downstairs and like
sleeps in the den or whatever
um but Heather
decides she's gonna stay in the Attic
room by herself and her logic was she's
like well I guess I thought that
whatever it was that was in the room was
after Brianna and that if Brianna wasn't
in there then it wouldn't bother me and
I'm like that doesn't sound like real
Sound Logic but whatever I mean I don't
know if I'd be wanting to stay in that
room with all that kind of [__] going on
but okay she was just kind of like oh
well it was after it was after my sister
[__] her you know what I mean it's like
I don't know it just seems like a really
weird thing to say
so uh so yeah
maybe she just wanted the room to
herself maybe that's what it was
so a couple days after that
um Heather is in her room that she now
has all to herself
and she's kind of blasting music in
there and then her mom comes up and is
like Jesus Christ turn the music down
are you trying to like you know make
everybody deaf or whatever so she turns
the music down and then after Mom leaves
she turns around and she sees a little
ghost girl essentially like standing
there at the door now this is not
explained this is not added to but I do
appreciate that they didn't really try
to like add this into any kind of
narrative you know what I mean
um because they just she just sees this
little girl and she said that she didn't
feel threatened by it
like she she said she wasn't it wasn't
real scary or anything I mean it's scary
obviously because it's like a ghost but
she said she didn't feel threatened by
it
so she sees it and then she heard that
very distinct sound like a body falling
down the stairs again
and she said that she assumed that maybe
this little girl had once lived in the
house and had like fallen down the
stairs or been pushed down the stairs or
something like that she was like trying
to convey that
um but like I said they never really do
go any further into that I don't think
anybody else saw the little girl again
after that but um Heather did say that
she saw her in the room
so when Heather tells her mom about this
Terry the mom she calls her sister
because her sister has lived in this
town for like a really really long time
and maybe would have heard something
about anything unusual like happening in
this particular house so she asked about
the house and all the sister can come up
with she's like well the house used to
be like they used to rent it out like as
a boarding house like back in the 1950s
but she's like as far as I know like
nobody died in there there was like no
tragedies or murders or anything like
that like there was nothing unusual
about it so that was kind of like the
end of that investigation they didn't
really bring it up again but come on put
some more ice in it
so then
um it goes quiet again for about a week
other than I thought this was kind of
funny I guess it just goes to show like
once you get used to like a baseline of
Paranormal Activity is just kind of like
well it went quiet for a week I mean you
know like pictures were still falling
over and like you know then we were
still hearing footsteps and stuff like
that but other than that like not you
know what I mean there wasn't like
anything like really big deal but there
was like some like a low level activity
I guess
so um but a few days after that Ethan
the eight-year-old
he's going upstairs to the room like
looking for Heather and when he goes
into the room I guess she's not in there
but like a baseball bat like picked
itself up off the floor or the bed or
wherever it was and like essentially
like came winging at him you know what I
mean uh he didn't get hurt or anything
like that but uh yeah so he goes up to
the room and like the [__] goes
through a baseball bat at him so that
wasn't nice at all
so after this
mom says to Heather you are not staying
in that room anymore either because
obviously there's some like [__] up
[__] going on in there
um and at this point too they start
talking well maybe we should move but
obviously like a lot of families in this
situation they're like we really
couldn't afford it we didn't have any
money and all the house money was tied
up in the house you know what I mean
so they're just like well um we're just
gonna have to pray
which
uh you know spoiler alert that really
didn't do Jack so
several weeks later
um [__] starts getting real
uh Brianna goes up to the room to get
something
and she's like they show like the shadow
figure dude like kind of swishing by
behind her and then it attacks her again
like essentially like kind of jumps on
her and then it locks her in the room
pretty much basically what happened
like so she starts screaming and
freaking out and like the mom is wigging
out and she goes up there and tries to
get the door open and she can't get the
door open she's like it just felt like I
just could not get that door open for
anything and so she runs downstairs to
get something to like bust the door
opens she goes it comes back with a
hammer or something like that so when
she comes back up with the hammer though
she's like it was completely silent by
the time I got back up there and then
the door just kind of creaked open by
itself and she was like freaking out
because she didn't know what was gonna
be behind the door like when it opened
so she goes in there and Brianna is just
like laying on the floor crying
she said that it was like a [__] like a
black shadow figure
and it was as tall as the ceiling that's
what she said and that it smothered her
like it was just honor and like
smothering they didn't have a face
either did it yeah I think that was
later that she said that
so at this point
um Brianna either at the behest of her
parents or for her own uh from her own
suggestion she actually goes and kind of
lives with uh family members nearby like
she still comes to the house like to
hang out with her family and stuff but
she doesn't spend the night there
anymore
um she sleeps at their their family
member's house because she's like not
having it anymore
so at this point they start to think
they'll bring in a paranormal research
group so they call this one that's
called the acronym is Casper
which I thought was so funny that I
forgot to write down what the acronym
stood for oh you know it was no it was
Center for Arkansas paranormal something
something yeah
paranormal something research I guess
but yeah it was Casper was the thing
well I was like oh that's kind of cute
though yeah
I just took the words
they took the name Casper and then just
tried to get something to fit in there
foreign
Amanda asked Tom and Jenny have you ever
watched Celebrity Ghost Stories I've
seen a couple episodes of it yeah
didn't we see one that was um what's her
face uh uh bulk was in here did you yeah
that was what because I would only watch
ones that I that were celebrities I give
a [__] about yeah but um yeah I think we
saw one with her didn't we see one with
Rose McGowan or am I completely tripping
I don't know don't remember that yeah
remember that one
maybe it was somebody else I'm not sure
I'd give much credibility to Rose
McGowan anyway in terms of [__]
ghosts ghosts
well you know just you know
she'd have motive to make a ghost story
up I don't know this may be in cynical
yeah probably
so um so yeah I think she calls cast
[__] she did tell [__] uh
uh [__] Eric Weinstein to shut the
[__] up though didn't he didn't she she
did yeah yeah I mean you got to give her
props for that right
oh what's his name [__] um
um went after him too which I kind of
got some respect for him uh Angelina
Jolie's Brad Pitt evidently Brad Pitt
[__] jumped at it and [__]
swinging at her to get you stay away
from state to stay away from her that
type of [__]
yeah yeah
I didn't hear about that yeah
well he didn't say that other people
said that that happened to him yeah that
that Brad Pitt [__]
basically [__] ran up on him says you
stay away from her
for him yeah yeah
uh Danny rolling said I saw the one with
furio from The Sopranos spilling his
guts about his ghost encounter yeah I
mean
I'm sure it's probably not our anymore
but I would I would watch it if it was
like a celebrity I liked that I thought
wasn't bullshitting
and Beverly D'Angelo did one too oh okay
I'll have to kind of watch that one man
I haven't seen her since the [__]
National Lampoon's Vacation movies I'm
sure you know who that is
she was in the National Lampoon's
Vacation the moms oh yeah yeah yeah like
the blonde yeah yeah
haven't seen her in forever yeah I mean
I'm sure she's been in other stuff
because like I said that's the thing
like a lot of actors are still around
it's just I don't see enough yeah stuff
to know that they're still around you
know what I mean because there's so much
content out there so it's like they
could very well be still working and I
wouldn't know anything about it
but so so they call it Casper not the
Friendly Ghost but the you know the
group
so the lady that runs Casper is named
Karen Shillings I think her name was so
she brings the team out to the house
like a week later and then of course
they have the psychic because of course
they do
now they said when they first came in
they had a compass and it in the front
room like the compass like
kept spinning around all crazy
so at this point they're like oh [__]
man your house is guess what a portal to
another dimension yeah the portal angle
I hate when that happens portal stories
yeah
I've seen paranormal [__] people all
right Jenny's witnessed it too
same part of the same event from Mammoth
Mountain
I don't know if I buy the portal thing
I mean anything may be possible
but I don't know man [__] that I tend
to think that if there's if there's one
anomaly it's some kind of a ghost it's
just one of them
if it seems to be many of them there's
still just one of them it's one of them
impersonating other things kind of like
you have a dream and in your dream
there's a lot of different characters in
your dream it's still just you dreaming
it's like that you know maybe uh
some kind of paranormal entity
is slightly in a way dreaming and it's
it's one thing one second and then it
says it thinks it's something else
another one
just uh I don't think it's very coherent
you know
Poltergeist wasn't totally coherent
it's just weird
um it's not like you're dealing with a
a coherent individual person more like a
force
more like a living dream or an invisible
dream that's moving things
it's weird yeah that's a good way of
putting it yeah Danny rolling said An
Origin show about how ghost hunting or
investigating even came about would be
pretty cool that actually would be quite
interesting I'm going to write that down
actually probably goes back to the Roman
area well I'd be curious to know like uh
uh what the words because I don't
actually know I mean I know a lot about
um you know the like spiritualism and
seances and all that kind of stuff but
like from Victorian era but I don't
really know much about ghost hunting
history
so much so that actually might be a good
I'll have to put that in the poll for
next week
let's see what comes up
for that but yeah that's actually a
really good idea
so uh so yeah
until I got a portal
um I think so you got a portal I think
that
um didn't they say something about maybe
this house is like a quote-unquote
natural portal like a electromagnetic
field well what's the other thing like
um you know a deliberate portal like
some like like a wizard made one or some
[__] or a psychic has opened up a damn
portal between two Dimensions oopsie
yeah yeah
like on purpose column for something
that always like to do all yourself
these Spiritual Beings come through it
I've had out of body experiences and
near-death experience [__]
spontaneous Out of Body Experience
um two different occasions
so I know the world that they're talking
about is
it's not a world where all the all the
ghosts are packed in together in one
spot and they're coming through like in
an elevator yeah
oh a Portal's open thank God
the vast empty space of mostly just
empty space and time and it doesn't flow
normally and
you can appear anywhere you want to in
any time you want to just by thinking
about it it's like going to another damn
chat room we're going into another video
in [__] YouTube it's like that yeah
like when Tom goes over there yeah
so
if you were to open a portal into the
astral plane there wouldn't be anything
there it would just be
you'd have a sensation though because it
happened to me that one time you know in
the barracks I [__] exteriorized I
was looking down on myself from above
and had a roommate in there he saw it
happen
[__] know there's a burst of [__]
psychokinetic energy happen it was
shaking the microwave shaking the
refrigerator making a microwave on top
of it kind of snap and pop
but you're not under any kind of
impression that you're not you're not in
under the impression that there are any
like Spirits right near you or anything
and I saw him moving underneath me just
a black cloud and he's kind of in
amorphous shape but all the the room it
was just different colors it's kind of
like rubbing your eyes you see those
weird colors there's three dimensional
versions of that it's hard to stay still
you're if you look at something you go
over there if you think of something you
go over there
and uh in the end I just thought about
my body and boom I was back in it so
if you were to open a portal like
they're describing it wouldn't be on the
other side of that [__] door it's 20
or 30 [__] goats yeah like they're
all just waiting for you but it would be
like that if you opened a portal it
would just be empty nobody would be over
there
they're all waiting there like it's
[__] Black Friday and they're waiting
for Walmart yeah it wouldn't be like
that
so that's why I don't really buy into
the portal thing I think that that is
the case of
people imposing the situation that
people are used to here
onto a dimension that may or may not
exist that we obviously don't understand
yeah you know it exists I've been there
or at least part of me has been there
um and we come from there and I was
aware of certain things happening at a
distance like a big ball of singing
lights and just singing lights an
episode what you would call a person
would say well it's heaven but I was I
knew that if you went into that you'd
never come back out you'd be recycled
your spiritual Essence would just become
one with this huge sea of [__] soul
material is what the Greeks call the
pleroma
the place where all [__] Souls come
from and place where the gods come from
and the angels come from there and you
know and it's outside of space and time
and
that's there
you're aware of things far away moving
talking
um but they don't really call they're
not real important to you you're aware
of little things moving around in your
vicinity they're kind of mindless maybe
like a little Mindless Soul Spirit kind
of like the spiritual version of a bug
or an insect or an animal but there's
not much to them
which makes me wonder somehow I don't
think they have the power to break
through into this dimension
it's weird to say that but
yeah hokey ass terms breaking through
into this Dimension it sounds corny as
[__] but if you've ever had an
out-of-body experience or a really
strong acid trip where you've got kind
of exterior eyes a little bit you know
what I'm talking about they say you can
kind of do it on [__] real powerful
hallucinogens and some of the ones that
I've been on yeah it's similar
I felt like I could probably exteriorize
or leave my body
if I wanted to there was one time I was
really trying to last time but Jenny
kept bothering me I wasn't bothering you
yeah you wanted to go outside and play
the damn garden and I was like no no you
got to stay inside the house
um so I had to kind of watch her father
it was her first time it was her first
time so couldn't really trust her but I
was trying to [__]
make my [__] head spin as fast as I
could inside my head in order to try to
come out
which is weird you have to be there to
understand what that means
you feel like your head's shaking back
and forth and I was like yeah yeah I'll
be out here in a minute I'm coming loose
but then she
kept walking around wow this is great
you know it's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
let's go outside and play like no no no
no no no no no no no yeah
flower garden thinking you were a
werewolf that's true yeah I did think
you said you were a werewolf I mean I
didn't you said I didn't actually think
I was a werewolf but I kind of did you
feel like you're a werewolf yeah you
know what I'm talking about I knew what
you're talking about if you haven't done
acid like you don't like you know that
you're not a werewolf yeah but on the
other side of it you kind of do think
you're well you know what I mean yeah
you were you were summoning it yeah it's
it it makes sense when you're it makes
yeah right so um
some of these uh theories some of these
spiritual theories that these
parapsychologists come up with they're
just trying to describe a phenomena that
they've witnessed or heard about or read
about
um or they've read about these portals
and now they think well this must be one
of those things I read about
it's all theoretical you know and the
people that are writing this haven't had
out-of-body experiences or any astral
projection they haven't seen what it
looks like and what reality is like over
there it's not the same rules
so go start playing they're not even
following time for them isn't quite the
same if that's where the ghosts are
I've never seen a ghost
like an apparition of a dead person
that's what I consider to be a ghost
moving around I've never seen that I
don't even know if they were if they're
real I know poltergeists are real but
that's not really a ghost
and I've been in houses that were bad
but I don't know if that's a ghost
either
it might be what
ancient people and Buddhists and stuff
and it's kind of passed down in Taoist
priests
kind of uh called evil places and then
we get it through Star Wars mythology
which is based on that kind of [__] is a
place that's strong with the dark side
and uh
it might just be that it's a place
that's very strong with a dark side
that that place might have a [__]
a personality to of its own in a certain
certain sense like inanimate objects may
have kind of like a soul or something
like a soul
which means that there's some bad places
in the [__] planet
death camps ex-death caps and [__]
there's a soldier I listen to named pops
Terence pops and he was a SF guy an
infantry guy and
when he was in Iraq he was put in charge
of Abu garib prison and he said that was
haunted as [__]
and he there's all kinds of [__] that
was going on in Abu garib prison before
the Americans took over tortures it was
like a death camp basically it was one
of saddam's death cabs and they had a
whole sections of it walled off
and uh he could hear voices and people
walking and things stir and inside
hole wings of the cells that were walled
off they were so scared of the place
because of what had happened in their
forcing guys to hang themselves to
escape torture and stuff
um they'd walk around the yard and
[__] hear some Crunch and look down
and it'd be a piece of a human spine you
know because they were just burying
people on the grounds
but uh he believed he he seemed
paranormal too while he was on duty
but yeah like I said I think that you
see that a lot on these kind of
paranormal shows is when they bring up
the whole concept of a portal like you
said they're they're imposing
um you know our experience on something
that they have no way of knowing about
so it's like in our world you know yeah
there'd be like a bunch of people like
packed in a house or something like that
so it's like so they're extrapolating oh
well in the afterlife or whatever the
[__] then it would be like that too
because they said oh well this is a
portal so this house is just like full
of entities you know what I mean and I'm
just like well I kind of feel like to me
if if this stuff exists and if this is
going on it's like why would they all
just be like crammed up in one house
they just they're not bound by temporal
reality or they don't really need to
stay there they wouldn't they wouldn't
know that a portal had been opened
unless they were in that area on the
other side
they wouldn't even know that it was open
and most most entities that I believe
based on my limited personal experience
with being out of body
a a being that you might call a ghost or
something that might do a haunting
is something it would be a being that's
mostly in its own world it's in its own
virtual reality
so it'd be hard to find it even in the
spiritual world it would be in its own
cubicle basically in its own reality
it'd be like if you're in the Internet
it's hard to [__] find
if without a search engine it would be
hard to find a certain
um uh uh website unless you knew the
name of it exactly right it'd be like if
you got to think of it like that you'd
have to know the exact address that's
actually a good um analogy right yeah
like if there was no such thing as
search engines right you'd never find
anything like you'd never find anything
and that's kind of what the spiritual
world was more like more like the
internet without a search engine but you
kind of had one if you had it something
in your mind like let's say you were
looking for a a particular person in
history in time you could access it
you'd appear there and you'd see like
you could see Socrates if he existed you
might as well there was
Socrates wasn't as we know and you know
you might see a recording basically a 3D
recording in history you're looking at
it back in time he goes yeah that's not
really the guy we we believed in oh and
his soul is here now he's not a Socrates
anymore he's something else he's been
recycled he went into the Roman didn't
come back out okay going into the
collective yeah going into the paroma
and not coming back out was being Star
Wars terminology becoming one with the
force and not not returning which in the
in a Star Wars world
people would become more of the forest
and that was it
one guy learned to come back the Qui-Gon
he figured out how to come back and some
and he taught other people how to come
back that's how
you could make a
Obi-Wan ghost yeah well of course yeah
he could kind of come back from it but
that's very rare
coming back from the pleroma
well yeah because you're just you become
you lose your identity right right and
you just become like assimilated with
like all the other with the universe
that's why Sith didn't want to [__]
die or become join become one of the
force they wanted to keep their identity
[__] yeah
I worked hard to build all this [__] I'm
not gonna have him wait I want to hang
out with those other people just pour it
into a sea of Souls and be erased [__]
no I'm gonna hold myself together I'm
not even gonna die
that's what that was with the Sith
wanted eternal life
they couldn't let it go yeah well what's
his name said he said you know he goes
the dark side of the force is a pathway
to abilities that some may consider to
be unnatural
yeah that was that's some freaky [__]
man
sucking the life out of living beings so
you could get younger that kind of [__]
vampirism type [__]
[Music]
keeping people from dying even though
they're mortally wounded like Vader was
mortally wounded but he's being kept
from dying by the emperor that's why he
couldn't betray him and then they put
him in a suit to help
so yeah so where were we okay okay so
this house like I said just full of
entities because you know portal whether
it's a natural portal or somebody made
it upper because we don't really know
they start doing uh some EVP stuff but
before they even really get into that
uh the psychic that they brought with
them I don't think they said what her
name was
but she starts uh essentially like
channeling so she starts like talking in
like some other creepy voice or whatever
this was also like pretty creep but like
I said I don't know if any of this
happened or not but it was like pretty
creepy like for the show
um so the psychic starts it has this
weird voice and she starts saying like
leave us alone we are not leaving like
all this other kind of stuff
so the next night after the
investigation
like you know the freaky [__] that
happened Blake the dad
we thought this was funny well like
we've made a joke about this he decides
he's gonna do his own thing he's gonna
do a man's investigation yeah I guess he
just didn't have no patience with all
these psychics and stuff he was very
silly I got no patience for this it's
Arkansas I gotta have answers
all the dudes on this show are so funny
because it's like they always want like
a concrete answer and a concrete
solution and there just isn't one and
they just don't know how to deal with
that they really have a hard time I like
the guy though he was funny you know
he's kind of like my dad I gotta have
answers I ain't letting these women just
tell me
I'm gonna find out for myself the dudes
on this show they have a very hard time
with ambiguity I forget yeah it's like
they always want something that's like
XYZ and that's the end of it it's like
well life isn't like that it's a very
masculine approach it is but everybody
has been approach she says I'm gonna put
up a camera
itself
[Laughter]
I'm gonna tell you what it is and we
were kind of making jokes too because
this takes place in Arkansas and I said
did they ever consider that this might
be the boggy creek creature yeah so that
brings it right back to Biden Creek too
and the Legends their accents are very
strong they're very different than like
a Mississippi southern accent I can see
how Outsiders can get them confused but
I'm like man no they're it's very
different man their [__] is [__]
strong you can still it's still
noticeably a Southern accent but it's
very very different and the women sound
real whiny real real whiny yeah
stretched out
stretched out words and you know what
they say
what do they say
I've never been to Arkansas
but uh but yeah so these people yeah
they have they have very very thick
accents very very thick accents
um so yeah so Blake's gonna do his own
man's investigation
so he sets up a camp lick which
basically entails I'm gonna set up a
camera to film myself sleeping in case
some like scary [__] happens that was it
seemed like the extent of it
so he sets it up on top
did he set it up like on a up like an
over to like an upturned like laundry
basket it looked like yeah and I was
like okay that's that's real high tech
or whatever so he puts like the camera
on there like to film himself while he's
sleeping
now apparently
his dresser drawer
opened by itself and then slammed
clothes and it's slamming clothes with
like it woke him up
so then
um when he looks at the like he checks
the camera and everything's okay and
he's like okay whatever I'm going back
to sleep but then like the next morning
they watched the footage well I guess he
watched it first and then he goes out to
the family he's like you guys got to see
this [__] right so he shows it to them
and apparently they all watch the tape
and he's like sleeping and they so you
see him getting up like with the door
open like the drawer opening and closing
and all that and then he gets back in
bed and then there's like
a face
they didn't show The Real Thing
obviously but the reenactment they
showed
it looked like this kind of face coming
up like from the on the end of the bed
or something like that like it came out
underneath the bed yeah and he said that
it looked like a face with a cat eye and
he said it looked demonic once again
they did not show the original footage
they never do they never so it must not
have been that impressive
yeah it was open to interpretation
it's emanastication right
it makes a world of difference man it
makes the world it would have been
funnier if there was like beer and maybe
like some bottle rockets involved they
should have got those dudes from [__]
killing Bigfoot
a real good we gonna have a man
a map in here we're gonna have a
mastication up in him
I'm gonna sit over here with the shotgun
you gonna sit over there with the camera
you ever sat over there with a light
when it shows up we want you to shoot
him yeah you want to get this [__] all
on Phil well they need somebody that
will tell you what it is after it's dead
yeah they need somebody to watch the
cooler and make sure that Sasquatch
doesn't steal their beer yeah just
saying just a trailer for killing
Bigfoot I just was like man I just was
busted up I was like I ain't watching it
rednecks jumping out of the ground with
[__] shotguns [__] flashlights
with a shotgun they're [__]
ridiculous
well yeah but that's the reason they're
in the South that's the reason they make
this [__] because they know people are
gonna be like that can't be a real show
[__] ground sitting a hole in the
ground with a board over their [__]
head yeah
[Laughter]
see like
like oh it's
it's in the ghost hunting shows yeah I
mean and I always make fun of the ghost
hunting shows it's like them walking
around like with that [__] night
vision camera in a warehouse or
something being like did you hear that
like it's just it's that for like 45
minutes yeah but it's like the killing
Bigfoot one is just gonna be like
rednecks sitting around drinking beer
sitting around in a trench making noise
flashing flashlights and every now and
then like a deer walks by and they all
wet their pants yeah so you know and you
could just you could just cut right to
the chase you just had a damn drone just
fly a drone over there with an IR camera
on it you'd see every [__] living
animal giving off a heat signature for
miles and miles and you wouldn't see
anything unusual but see that wouldn't
be here yeah raccoon
squirrels asleep up in our little nests
and [__] I just remembered that on my
way to work yesterday or Friday I saw a
turkey just standing on the side of the
highway yeah all by himself yeah a
little wild turkey I was like holy [__]
there's no Bigfoot people
I mean I kind of feel if there is a
fountain by now if there's anything like
that in the United States it'd be
somewhere in Washington state but it'd
probably be in Canada
I
I don't think it's there either
it would have to be something in a
warmer climate and that the habitat's
gone
Amanda said turkey's in Florida
yeah we got turkeys yeah we got wild
turkeys down here yeah you don't see
them a lot but I do see them every now
and then they're all over the South yeah
it wasn't fat it wasn't like one that
you get from a turkey like a farm like
for Thanksgiving he was like a skinny
wild turkey like a long like the size of
the pee was just hanging out on this
side it's only a little bit bigger than
a duck yeah it's only a little bit
bigger than a dog he said Bigfoot is an
alien
I love that I love that how when they
couldn't come up with
you know any evidence that Bigfoot
existed like as an animal because that
seemed a sort of reasonable proposition
they started saying well maybe he's an
interdimensional being and that's why we
can't yeah I was just kidding I was like
come on he's an Indian Spirit yeah
an E.T indian spirit I'm like has has it
ever occurred to you that maybe the
reason you haven't found it is because
it's not there yeah you know what I mean
that's the new thing is to say that it's
interdimensional yeah that's yeah that
happened like a few years ago that like
started to they're starting to integrate
like all the Paranormal things they want
it to be like all part of one thing they
have to explain why they don't find any
food exactly that's what I'm saying
because everybody just kept saying why
haven't you found anything why haven't
you found any bodies well yeah where the
footprints whereas anything and like I
said now that we have like satellite and
everything like that it's like you know
you'd think we would have found it well
um it can go into other dimensions
that's why yeah yeah okay it's an Indian
spirit
let's go come yeah I mean just just stop
I mean I get like I have a lot more
respect for somebody that just says
um you know I know there's no scientific
evidence but I just think it's neat so I
believe in Bigfoot just because I think
it's neat like it would be a cool idea
like I'm hoping there's a Bigfoot but
like the second that you start coming up
with all these [__] wild theories
about like why they can't find one or
why they can't like because it's from
space or whatever I'm just like okay
it's like uh Monster yeah That's What
Tammy just said if you'd like to have a
monster and a Loch Ness but there's no
there's no food and not Loch Ness yeah I
mean it'd be cool and everything I don't
like to have to go around it like [__]
on everyone's like you know fantasy
stories and everything like that but
it's just like it's probably just
doesn't exist I'm sorry if there was a
Loch Ness monster there'd have to be a
whole breeding population which means
dozens of them and they wouldn't be
[__] hide and they'd be laying up on
the bank [__] taking sun and go look
at these [__] boats you know that 'd
be like a herd of Anna like I said it
wouldn't occur to them to like hi it
didn't occur to them to be like it'd be
like elephants elephants don't hide yeah
why would they walk around they don't
have any conceptives like no oh I'm not
supposed to exist you're right yeah I
better get out of here they'll get out
later eat and challenge a car never in
India [__] out of the [__] Street you
know the elephant telling the car to get
off the street this is my road you know
they don't hide that's what the way
those things would be
it'd be worse because they'd be like a
dinosaur
Danny rolly said Bigfoot can cloak
himself in invisibility sort of like a
Jedi mind trick yeah
murder Hornet said I hate ghost hunting
shows where someone says something just
grabbed me yeah they do that a lot yeah
I'm like how are the audience supposed
to know you're not lying that's no
evidence yeah exactly they're just doing
that just to make the show exciting
because otherwise it would just be like
a bunch of chodes sitting around in a
[__] dark warehouse and absolutely
nothing happening you know what I mean
that's what's really happening because
that's what's really happening if you
were really there it would just be
really really boring yeah so they always
just have to say just like did you hear
that oh my God something touched me
something breathed on me you know what I
mean I'm like no it didn't knock it off
so uh so yeah so the man's investigation
so yeah so he sees a face he said it
looked like a face with a cat eye and he
said it looked demonic of course
now there was also a voice on the thing
and of course it just kept saying evil
evil evil like over and over and over I
was like that's creative
I think it would be creepier if it had
said something else maybe that's all
they could think of for it to say just
say evil evil over and over again I
don't know
so a few days after that uh Karen the
the lady from Casper
she comes back and she's like oh I got
all those EVPs like I listen all the
EVPs we recorded in here and there's
like some pretty freaky [__] on here so
the EVPs they recorded like there was a
whole bunch of them like a whole bunch
of different voices
um some of them said leave this house uh
some of them said we hate you I'm like
rude okay
um and then there was one where they I
guess one of them asked like tell us who
you are and he said the devil and I was
just like again creative what a [__]
even the ghosts are Edge Lords what the
[__] so uh so yeah Karen basically says
I thought this was funny too so Karen is
like look I'm just a lowly Paranormal
Investigator
um this is like some [__] this is way
beyond my pay grade I don't really know
what what to do I don't know I don't
know what to tell you
um so
she's like I'm just kind of washing my
hands of the whole situation
so at this point they call a pastor to
come and you know kind of and bless the
[__] as you would now while the pastor
is there uh they said there was like a
rush of cold wind you know during the
blessing
um and a feeling of evil you know yeah
I've had that feeling uh also they had
like some paper or something like blue
in the pastor's face I don't know if
that really happened or not but maybe
they just thought it'd be funny to do
that to the actor
um so Terry said that while they were
doing while they were doing it like
while the pastor was there like she knew
that the prayer wasn't working that it
wasn't gonna do [__] so you know what I
mean
so that didn't really amount to anything
so later on that night
um Heather
is sleeping in a room like she's kind of
like half asleep or whatever and she
hears somebody coming into the room now
she thinks it's her brother Ethan
because again like you know he's eight
so he like gets scared sometimes and
he's like you know comes up and gets in
bed with his sister because he's
freaking out it's like having a
nightmare or whatever
so he's so she thinks it's him
and she said she heard somebody come in
the room like heard the creaking and
felt the weight on the bed and like felt
the covers move and everything and then
she turns over though
and she said she saw very clearly that
there was an indentation on the bed and
like the covers raised like someone was
laying there but nobody was there so
like it was like an invisible person
like laying in the bed which I'm not
sure if that would be scary or if it'd
be scarier like that there was like a
monster there I'm not really sure
invisible would be pretty scary I gotta
admit but yeah so she said there's
nothing there so she starts praying to
Jesus I'm like yeah Jesus is like I'm
sorry I can't help you but you know what
I mean
um and Heather at this point you know
she was the one that wanted to stay in
this room after Brianna like left a long
time ago but at this point this was her
that was like the straw that broke the
camel's back I guess she's like yeah I'm
out of this room too so she never slept
in that room again she actually went
down and started sleeping in the den
and Ethan the younger boy like wouldn't
sleep in his room anymore either
so a few days later uh Karen that from
Casper she comes back and she wants to
spend the night in the house like in the
girl's room like in the scary attic room
like over the garage like she wants to
spend the night in there
now so she's sleeping in the bed
and she has the same experience that
Heather had in the sense that you know
something comes in she feels a weight
like something is getting in bed with
her and at first it's like invisible but
then she turns around to look at it and
it was
a figure like she said it was a black
shadowy
man looking figure with no face and she
said that it was like a black
hole like with swirling Mist in it
that's how she described it right
because she the actual lady was like on
the show
so she said where its face was and
actually the special effect here was
like pretty good I really do I really
like the way they did it it was like
really creepy so it's just like this
kind of amorphous looking like black
figure but then its face was like this
weird swirling nebula kind of [__] she
said waves of what depression and evil
were coming off of it and it was like it
was seeping into you and sucking you in
says you couldn't move
yeah she said she felt smothered and
like she couldn't
like it was holding her there right kind
of like for a long time
so she said I guess that happened for
like a while but then like she said it
finally kind of disappeared or like
lifted off her or whatever
so the next morning uh Karen comes
downstairs after that experience and
tells Terry the mom
um well again not really sure there's
much you guys can do in this situation
because I saw the [__] and um it's very
very powerful and it absolutely does not
want to leave
so she's like so I would recommend that
you guys leave because I don't really
think there's anything else you could do
so they finally decide at this point
yeah we probably do have to move out so
I guess they just kind of like bite the
bullet and move they I guess she said
that um they had a family member that
had a bunch of rental properties that
let them move into one of their houses
they're like it was really really small
and it was kind of like uncomfortable
and stuff but it was like a good deal so
they had somewhere they could move to
but a few weeks after that Heather
actually goes up to the room by herself
like to get some stuff like while while
they're in the process of moving and I
guess there's like she said there was
this cold gust of air like coming from
the bathroom and then she sees a dark
figure with the swirly face although in
her case I don't know if she actually
said this out right but what they showed
in the reenactment was that it looked
like
kind of like the little girl ghost she'd
seen earlier except it was all black and
with the swirly face like the creepy
dude guy had been so I don't know if
that was the case or not because like I
said the the time before where she had
seen like the little girl ghost
she said she wasn't scared of it you
know what I mean but this was like a
different situation so I don't really
know
so the family moves away
two days after that
um Terry and Heather
I think and you know what's funny Zach
is here still right yeah I think Zach
said something about this episode I
don't know if he knew that it was this
episode that he was talking about but I
I it triggered Something In My Memory
that he said something in the chat like
a long time ago they went back to the
house
after they moved away to get a phone
charger that they had forgotten in the
house and I think Zach said something
about this like the family went back to
get the phone charged like just buy
another phone charger they're like
they're like [__] 10 or something
like that and so that's what I I just
remembered that like you had said that
and I was like oh this is the episode
that he was talking about where it's
like all this haunting [__] was going on
they move away and they're like oh no I
forgot my 10 phone charger better I'm
like go to Walgreens and get another one
what the [__] so they have to go back to
the house to get it
and uh so while they're in there all
kind of like [__] paranormal
Shenanigans like start taking a look
like the doors start slamming and the
lights are flashing and all kind of [__]
and they're just like okay fine like
we're going it's like we don't need the
phone charger that bad like I said just
go to [__] Walgreens and get another
one it's fine
so um Heather then said
um because she was I guess it was
Heather that was the one that was on the
show I don't think Brianna was on there
but of the other family members were on
there
but um she said that the family that
moved in after them
she heard I don't know how she knows
this but she heard that they had sealed
off the upstairs like I'm assuming she
means that room that her sister that her
and her sister
stayed in I'm assuming that they she
means they sealed that off and they
didn't use it but then she also said
that sometimes when you walk by the
house the bathroom light would be on up
there even though nobody was supposed to
be in there yeah so
so there's that so that's yeah that's
pretty creepy that's pretty creepy yeah
Zach says so dumb it's just it's funny
because the second they said they went
back for the phone charger I remembered
you saying something about that like
when we were talking and that was like
it was months ago that you that you
mentioned that like the episode where
they went back for the phone charger all
right well I thought it was a good
episode it is it's a really good episode
it's right it's really it's fun to watch
I don't know how much of this has been
exaggerated and what they actually
changed of the witness testimony to get
it you know
in into the shape that they of this
episode that they wanted I mean you know
it
may be heavily exaggerated I don't know
I got a feeling that it's just another
Poltergeist case
um then investigators gotten got
involved in it and they blew it up into
like this major [__] haunting that's
got portals and [__] Bunches of
different ghosts in it and
apparitions and doppelgangers
doppelgangers
but you know doppelgangers
that I think that that had been reported
a couple times in Fairly CR fairly
credible Poltergeist yeah it's not super
common but it's not uncommon either and
every now and then uh
apparitions
are reported in a poltergeist case I
think it just might be a poltergeist
case because you got two young girls
you're there you know usually you have
to have
young people involved with Poltergeist
yeah and this was an eight-year-old boy
and two teenage girls yeah that's about
right and they're in a kind of a
tumultuous environment maybe and they're
having fun and the Synergy brought it
about so you talk about it kind of
opened a portal in that way
but it doesn't lead the spirit world
leads into the [__] subconscious mind
and one of them girls or both of them
maybe working together
to have um recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis
so it might have just been psychokinesis
it's just that they're not aware that
they're doing it
that'd be pretty hardcore though like if
it was manifesting doppelgangers of
friends and family yeah well you wonder
how does it manifest a physical top
again is it making an image that you
that is there in space that sounds
inefficient be more efficient to make
you make a person think that they saw
the doppelganger by putting the image
directly in their mind
yeah so it's probably nothing there it's
hallucination
you're forced because that would be a
lot easier making things than making a
3D moving object right
probably what it is is that you use your
psychic abilities to reach into the mind
of a person and put a a hallucination in
it they see an image
that'd be the way to do it they wouldn't
know the difference
would that freak you out more than would
it freak you out
seeing like just an like an app like a
general Apparition like I said like a
black fat shadow figure like even with
no face or seeing an apparition of like
or seeing like a doppelganger of like me
and like if you knew I wasn't here and
then like you saw me doing some creepy
[__] like I was just walking out of the
hall going hi Tom or like some [__] like
I've been in situations like that with
the Poltergeist but that's what I'm
asking you like would that be scary it
would be equally weird because to me I
think I would be more scared of like a
doppelganger not no matter what kind of
image you're seeing you're gonna it's
gonna play havoc on your mind if you see
a doppelganger of a person your words
are going to be like well when I see the
person for real you know what I mean how
do I know if I'm actually see that's
what bothers me about it maybe I'll be
talking to Jenny right and it's not and
it's not her and it's actually see
that's why it's scary right that see
exactly but if it's not that you're just
seeing an apparition you're like and
your mind would start [__] with you
like this okay I'm see I saw this image
of the thing is that the way it really
looks or is that just the way it wants
me to think that it looks
and it looks kind of it looks scary what
if it actually looks much scarier than
that and it really shows me what it
really looks like one of these days
you're gonna be worried about that too
so you're gonna you're gonna worry about
either one
I don't know I kind of feel like I mean
that would be scary I'm not saying that
wouldn't be scary like just saying like
a shadow figure or whatever with no face
like with a swirly face that's like
pretty creepy okay but what you said
about then like vents forward you seeing
a doppelganger of somebody that you know
that lives with you and stuff like that
um and then you never be able to being
able to like trust if that's the real
one or not like to me that's like way
scarier yeah it's not scary though
because you know you're not
ugly frightening looking you know
but it could show you and not most of
the time right you could show you the
image of damn rotten corpse you know
what I mean that's real disgusting you
know
inopportune times you know or it shows
you an image of a [__] horrible demon
so it's a lot worse if you ask me
at least if it's showing you a
doppelganger or people you know it kind
of at least looks Pleasant
[Laughter]
but it would play on your mind yeah I
think the fact that it's subverting
something that you well because that
also suggests an intelligence which is
frightening because it knows to subvert
something that you know and love into
something sinister so to me that that
whole implication is much scarier to me
because it's very easy to make something
scary like just generically scary you
know oh I'll just make an apparition if
something that looks like a killer clown
or like a [__] vampire or whatever it
is you know what I mean like or a rotten
corpse like you said but the just the
insidiousness of
making something that looks and sounds
like
your loved one
um to me like suggests a much greater
evil I guess
so to me that's scary during Mammoth
Mountain I was afraid it was going to
show me like
a writing course of what it looked like
because my idea generic idea of where
ghost looked was like something out of a
damn
horror yeah book it's like you know a
skeleton and a robe basically you know
with holding a lantern with a chains you
know what I mean that was kind of yeah
right I thought it you know it might
take on a shape that would be you know
horrifying
see but I kind of feel like and maybe
that's just because one I'm older and
two I'm like you know I I really I've
watched a lot of horror movies I always
feel like and I always say this when we
talk about haunting it's like whenever
they show like the role over the top
apparitions it's like oh it looks like a
rotten corpse I kind of feel like even
if I saw that I'd be like bro tone it
down some yeah I think it's much scarier
when it's like I said more restraint
doppelganger [__] is scarier I know yeah
when you're 18 when you're 13 that
doesn't scare you what scares you is a
[__] skeleton or a or a body or you
know that's what that that's gonna skip
I'd be like you're trying too hard
yeah to your [__] hair [__] stands
up like that because you're actually
seeing it you know well yeah you know
what I mean I'm just say it obviously
you're just talking if you actually were
to see something well no I'm just saying
like even on a haunting when we talk
about haunting episodes when they say
it's like oh I saw like a thing that
looked like a skeleton or something like
that for to me that's not as creepy as
seeing I mean the [__] in this episode
where she saw her sister and like talked
to her for a long time and then she's
like I love you like and it wasn't her
like to me that's like way creepier
that's way creepier than seeing
something that just looks looks like a
skeleton or something well what I
thought was creepier was from the
snedeker case the way in one of the
pilot episodes
the dude with the [__] beard
remember the eyes and the beard the guy
in the suit
oh yeah yeah I know what you're talking
about that would have [__] scared me
yeah because well he didn't look like
overtly monstrous no anybody was talking
to him right he said it was talking to
him you know I don't know how truth
snedeker case is
um evidently that story grew over time
it did yeah but um it evidently was
playing on his mind and [__] telling
him to [__] kill people and [__]
[__] get working him into a frenzy it
was just some evil dude in a suit with a
[__] beard but he he described a
bunch of different
beings that they were I think they all
were describing different apparitions in
this not a good case
Hugo said uh like in the movie it
follows sometimes it was someone you
know or love yeah and I think that was
why a lot of people responded to that
movie and why I really like that movie
and I thought that movie was like really
really creepy is because you never knew
um who the it was like it could have
been anybody it could have been like a
random person it could have been like
you know your brother your sister your
mom it could have been anybody so to me
that's like way scarier because you
don't really know
um I know Zach says uh what [__] me up
most in this show was the burnt up dude
harassing the teen girl in Texas the
makeup job they did on him was
horrifying like wait a minute this show
like that what are you talking about
yeah I don't know what he's talking
about either that or they're talking
well they were talking about some of the
other show like some of the other serial
killers that we did um like Willie
picked in the pig farmer guy and they
were talking about her Baumeister and
all that
um and Charles Eng and all them
they were talking about that so maybe he
was talking about that I'm not really
sure
um but yeah yeah oh [__] it is almost
nine o'clock okay so
um we probably should wrap it up because
I'm gonna have to get ready for bed soon
because you know gotta get up early and
all oh [__] all the tablets fall to the
floor yeah Poltergeist did that
uh but yeah so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this discussion about nightmare
upstairs
um so we'll be back again on Wednesday
night the topic that won in the poll
overwhelmingly was guess what good old
Jared Fogle the subway spokesman gone
wrong
so that's really wrong so yeah so that's
what we're going to be talking about uh
on Wednesday night so that should be a
fun show that we'll get immediately
demonetized we'll have to use like some
euphemisms and stuff I guess but uh you
know what I mean there are others you're
talking about you don't know who Jared
Fogle is no I imagine most people don't
yeah they do he is super famous
everybody knows yeah never heard this
guy you've never heard of Jared Fogle no
he was the subway spokesman
for years and years and years he lost
like 200 something pounds like eating
Subway sandwiches very very fast in the
2000s and then later uh there was uh
some CP yeah yeah allegations all right
some kitty prawns let's call it that
kitty prawns
cats and shrimps yeah
Kitty prawns but uh yeah yeah Ben says
jokes about prison footlongs and coming
yes I've heard them all I've heard them
all I've heard the smaller pants jokes
I've heard all of that but if that
smaller pants joke is actually funny but
um you know what I mean I saw I was
watching a documentary about it today
and the guys told that joke and
everybody was like oh my God that was
like the so wrong but it was like the
funniest joke it is a funny joke but I'm
pretty sure he didn't come up with it
because I was like I think I heard that
joke like a long time ago
um but he didn't really acknowledge
where it came from but I can't remember
where it came from though but I'm pretty
sure he didn't come up with it I think
he like thought he got it from someplace
else but yeah so that's what we're going
to be talking about on Wednesday night
show
so hopefully you guys can join us for
that so yeah have a good rest of your
evening you guys have a good day
tomorrow and we'll see you again on
Wednesday night good night